erika arango voto con ilusión en la
primera vuelta lleva 20 años vendiendo
artesanías tradicionales en quito y
esperaba que ya q pérez ganara las
elecciones para ver a un presidente que
diera valor a su cultura indígena ahora
ya no confía en nada ella q debió de
presionar más mi sentir es que
como mujer ecuatoriana
yo estoy decepcionada de la política y
esta decepción se traducirá en las urnas
así realmente yo también voy a votar por
el nuevo tono ese es el llamado del
partido indígena pachakutik que mantiene
sus denuncias de fraude electoral y que
trata de mantener vivo el impulso que
llevó a ya q pérez a conseguir un
resultado insólito en la primera vuelta
con casi el 20 por ciento de los votos
de difundir el voto nulo de absoluta
nulidad como una protesta social como
una indignación de todo el fraude que
vivió este proceso electoral sin embargo
al contrario de su partido el mismo ya q
pérez no quiso dar ninguna consigna
concreta a sus votantes muchos de ellos
se sienten perdidos y todavía arrastran
frustración se gastó como se suele decir
popularmente lo que teníamos de lo que
no teníamos
floresmilo un dirigente indígena ve un
horizonte oscuro pero nosotros vemos el
escenario bastante bastante complejo y
difícil el cual con cualquiera de los
dos ahora el nivel de conflictividad
social va a ser casi la misma después de
un desempeño espectacular en la primera
vuelta a las divisiones del voto
indígena amenazan su futuro y la
oportunidad de consolidarse como una
alternativa real en la política
ecuatoriana